i want to start today with what is
happening in
cuba which is both uh horrifying and
it's fascinating it's politically
relevant and of course we're
all globally as we'll talk about in a
moment
every country in some way dealing with
not just coronavirus generally but also
this resurgence of the virus despite
vaccinations starting to roll out
because of the very contagious delta
variant
all of this relates to what's going on
in cuba so let's start there
a very good article in the bbc
explaining generally speaking what's
happening in cuba
right now if you've not been following
it there are essentially
three issues here that are leading to
massive
protests in cuba first is
as is written here the coronavirus
crisis
the protests the bbc rights appear to be
the result of societal
exhaustion stemming from acute economic
and health crises
the pandemic and economic measures taken
by the government have made life in cuba
increasingly difficult
the pand the island which had kept the
pandemic under control in 2020 has seen
infections explode in recent week weeks
we'll look at those numbers
momentarily but records in terms of
daily infections
in terms of deaths the health care
system on the brink
of collapse that is one piece of it and
the hashtag
soscuba has been trending on twitter
uh this is one of the you know one of
the areas that
we've seen open slightly in cuba is that
of
internet access and now that leading to
the sos cuba hashtag uh which the
government is not
thrilled with and we will talk about
that in a moment number two
the economic situation tourism is
uh one of the main engines for the cuban
economy
almost completely paralyzed as a result
of the coronavirus pandemic
in addition cuba is seeing inflation
blackouts food shortages as well as
shortages of medicine and basic products
those aren't new issues
but they have been particularly worse
lately at the beginning of the year the
government proposed a new package of
economic reforms that while increasing
wages triggered a spike in prices
uh prices economists such as pavel vidal
from the pontificia caveriana university
of cali in colombia estimate prices
could rise between 500 and 900 percent
in the next few months starting to look
like my birth country of argentina from
the standpoint of
inflation and then number three
internet access before sunday the
largest protest cuba had seen since the
start of castro's communist revolution
took place in august of 94. many cubans
had no idea what happened because of
lack of internet access 30 years on the
scenario is different
under the presidency of raul castro cuba
has liberalized
taken some liberalizing steps which
increased internet connectivity and as i
mentioned earlier as a result of that
cubans have been using social networks
to express dissatisfaction with the
government
mainly young people now have access to
facebook twitter and
instagram and this platform uh was these
platforms were used
to organize the protests so
then we look at well what is the u.s
perspective
on this because the u.s has had
crippling sanctions on cuba
for a very long time sanctions that
while i am not a communist
and i am against the way that uh
cuba has operated with no open elections
for decades
despite promises made during the 1950s
and 60s i'm completely against that i
also recognize the total hypocrisy
of the u.s saying well we can't
tacitly endorse the way cuba is run and
so we're putting sanctions on them
and yet we have the relationship we have
with saudi arabia and many other
countries okay so i've talked about that
before
joe biden yesterday during a press event
bringing up
the cuban protests and saying the u.s
stands with the people of cuba take a
look at this
okay folks i want to start by
recognizing remarkable protests that are
taking place in
cuba with the cuban people demanding
their freedom
from an authoritarian regime and i don't
think we've seen anything
like this protest in
a long long time if quite frankly ever
the united states stands firmly with the
people of cuba
as they assert their universal rights
and we call on the government
government cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people of cuba and we're also
closely following the developments in
haiti
so this is a complicated issue
um and anybody you know you you've got
a lot of very right-wing cubans
in florida for example who love trump
and who are saying uh we need to
continue crushing the cuban government
and punishing it
we're just punishing the people if we do
that on the other hand
we also have to recognize that part of
why
things are the way they are in cuba is
because of american policy towards cuba
for decades and so
anybody who wants to sort of pigeonhole
me
on this issue and say well but so david
are you for or against or what you put
no we have to recognize that on the one
hand
the u.s has had a major role in keeping
things
worse in cuba than they could otherwise
be
we should be easing the sanctions that
trump put in remember that barack obama
eased some sanctions donald trump came
in
and reinstituted a lot of those
sanctions and although joe biden is on
the one hand saying we're with the cuban
people
the very sanctions that joe biden has
not eased that were put back in place by
donald trump
are part of why things are so bad at the
same time
i have been unquestionably against the
authoritarian regime in cuba
all of this time but we must recognize
that the u.s is friendly with many
authoritarian regimes
and so singling out cuba has been a
hypocrisy for decades obviously my main
concern
is the cuban people and um these are
massive and significant protests because
of the internet access
this may be we're seeing the repression
from the police state of cuba
and we're getting reports of you know
officers on every corner
and any everything you can imagine
would go on is going on at the same time
we can't ignore the u.s role
in uh cuba being at least partially the
way that it is now
we'll see over the next 48 hours the
direction that the government responds
to the protest is going to take
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of
confidence when it's time all you have
to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription
the medication comes straight to your
home within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an
entire month's supply for free when you
use the promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping